voici le centre de toutes les attentions
aux ânes l'épicentre de l'épidémie du
nouveau coronavirus est sous tension et
les personnes contaminées sous haute
surveillance
nous avons sept patients aux soins
intensifs précise la directrice de ce
centre d'isolement isolé également la
ville pour tenter d'enrayer l'épidémie
avec des mesures exceptionnelles
suspension des transports en commun dès
jeudi matin plus d'avion ni de train en
partance de rome
les résidents invités à rester et vise
étrangers à se tenir à l'écart les
autorités chinoises vont comprendre que
l'on se trouve à un moment critique
youtube rendre votre audio ce
responsable explique que le virus se
transmet par voie respiratoire et
pourrait muter et que cela accroît les
risques de propagation
voilà qui complique les mesures de
contrôle dit il en ajoutant qu'il ne
faut pas prendre la situation à la
légère
message reçu cinq sur cinq par les
chinois qui portent des masques
[Musique]
comme six passagers qui partent au
nombre des centaines de millions de
chinois qui participent à la plus grande
migration humaine annuel au monde pour
fêter le nouvel an en famille
mais l'épidémie force
cette étudiante a changé ses plans pour
cette fête je vais définitivement éviter
les endroits bondés du teil la moitié
des provinces du pays sont touchées
alors les masques sont en rupture de
stock comme ici à shanghai et dans cette
pharmacie de pékin on confirme qu à part
de l'alcool à friction
il ne reste plus de gels et autres
produits acceptés par tout est vendu dit
l inquiétude et vigilance
oui mais ce n'est pas encore la panique
aurait été moins plusieurs comme celle
ci affirme que la situation était
beaucoup plus tendue lors de la crise du
sras ce durant cette crise en 2002 2003
la chine avait longtemps caché la
gravité de la situation à sa population
cette fois pékin assure qu'il dévoile
les informations à temps et qu'il
collabore avec l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
le défi pour le pouvoir chinois projeté
transparence et compétences et éviter
que cette épidémie ne se transforme en
crise politique
cher ici annick bureaud base au canada
pk